you know you can you can see yourself in
those shoes and
something else i really was something
else something else
what what i i had a list what happened
there i don't know what happened
to something else i really heard those
guys this isn't mike tyson came out here
[Laughter]
well if it isn't youtube oh hello my old
friend
what are we watching today my friend
we're watching invincible episode
six it's called you look kind of day out
look a little dead look kind of bad
all right guys well you know the drill
you got to hit that like button and if
you enjoyed this
at all and then slide it subscribe and
click the notification bell you know for
our next reactions especially because
that next one might be late because i
have to
edit all of that one by myself wow just
speaking of which thanks for thumb
gindal for
editing the reaction highlights on this
one hey
the full-length watch longs for this
guess where they're at
you know where that website that every
youtuber's using now
spend your cash wisely by joining the
patreon.com
surreal rejects today you get
you know reactions to a whole bunch of
shows red highlights and watch so long
as incl
okay it's been about a minute we're good
to go let's go you got it let's do it
[Music]
white chicks i like white chicks
oh hey excuse me my dad owns chest and
pharmaceutical
and like half this universe
whoa like half this universe
do one or ideally all of you want to
have sex tonight and get in on the
ground floor of my inheritance well how
could you refuse
me and my huge
trust fund oh
hey let me up [ __ ] unless they kept
his underwear on
yeah you know give some dignity oh jesus
oh
[ __ ]
i think we can all agree you're better
without vocal cords
and don't worry about those prototypes
you're going to be different
you're going to be beautiful oh my god
you're going to be in
oh blood
yeah more blood oh i think i know i
think i know what that was i think it
was robot psychopath
oh that thing is robots needle won't go
in
oh no oh no
oh jesus ah
oh no daughter is that just kill her
monster girls physiology extensively
please stand aside
what get him out of here security
you can attest but then she dies
or you can assist me and we can save her
life
[Music]
we get a saline infusion of two percent
belladonna root five percent wool spain
we don't have that then get it nano
sutures
is dropping people on it
battle beaches had to beat your ass to
bring your powers back black samson
uh oh marital spouses
i mean myrtle disputes
huh mark this is so dark mark
dark dark mark hearing a dog bark bark
how long was i
out you smug six days
no no i i was supposed to uh amber
amber go away i covered for you i told
her you got hit by a bus
ooh i still can't believe you wouldn't
let me see you in the hospital yeah they
had uh
weird rules about visitors pandemic yeah
i'd basically already dumped you that
night i know
and i've thought a lot about that these
last couple of days
remember when i first called you you let
me start over can we do that again
start over i got hit by a bus take him
back out of pity
make it work make it work yeah i don't
deserve
to start over hey handsome mark grayson
i'm glad you've still got that pretty
face of yours oh i like you
me too so uh want to hang out sometime
oh i would not know how to commit to
that bit in real life
i'd be like how would he possibly know
this she's doing the calling
[Laughter]
you ain't even looking at her i love it
i love all of that remember
rick the guy you couldn't stop talking
about last summer anyway he's at upstate
u i'm going for a tour on friday
staying over they have a very handsome
pre-med program
can i come what i want to come
and i want to bring amber i'm a child
i'm sorry
said you want to come let him come
she's right as a person are we talking
about two separate things
i'm skipping college anyway what when i
was at the community center with amber
something clicked for me
i think i can help more people by just
helping them i can irrigate deserts
stop natural disasters bring food to the
star
is she gonna turn evil well i don't i
don't
feel that i don't feel that i think she
just doesn't want to follow anybody's
anybody's thing anymore she wants to
follow her own path but she doesn't have
a man to look after her powers
she will be evil everybody knows a woman
needs a man to do anything in life
the show taught me right yeah last week
that's the purpose of this show can't be
invincible without a man oh my god here
he comes
william come here what's up rick
is what's his name i don't know kevin
he's a gay best friend nameless gay best
friend
get it you want a fresh start give up
this superhero crap
it's gonna get you killed what if he's
right the worst day of my life is when
you got pass
wow what uh
what jesus dad why would you say that
that's so
mean bye dad
broke my heart damn that was so cruel
our focus is therefore on extending
quality of life
even if we can't extend life itself oh
please
ah mr sinclair all human failings are
simply
engineering challenges crying out to be
solved
we're machines and the sooner we
recognize that
is it robot i don't think it is it's not
robot yeah it's just dude with a
punchable face as well you're impressive
oh no you're the next target rick
uh oh okay wanda
[Music]
it's a start sorry just build whatever
you want man that's
amazing make your own town well you
don't need to go to college you're right
make your own college if you two want
some time to wander we can meet back
here in a few hours
that's a great idea see you both back
here in a while ooh
after doing something you know
intimate conversations getting to one
another
very connected look right ah two hot
dogs representing no
no no they're having conversations
where's flash
y'all look so cute oh
you make my heart smile i like seeing
them in a good place yeah it's gonna
last forever
because that's how all these superhero
properties go hey lovebirds
did you have a good time we're back
from studying
oh no
even like a cyclops robot some kind of
man robot thing
oh look at her she's the real hero
yeah oh good i thought he was
something's about to happen to that girl
[Music]
no
oh no mark do something dude please
come on man oh oh no
oh he got dressed real fast he's a
superhero
[Music]
[Music]
yes
still want to go to college marcus
okay you have to tell amber after this
no no
damn it mark come on come on man
see you no more come on man
somebody do something please no one can
what could i do
oh my god
ah i gotcha gotcha
oh god
oh no oh
no
oh
geez you're invincible you are
please you can't tell anyone i can't
believe this
it all makes sense now holy [ __ ] holy
[ __ ]
oh wow guys the police are on their way
where the hell did you
oh no that was gonna happen if that's
not some spider-man [ __ ] i don't know
what it is
this isn't what it looks like you took
off you left us here
you gotta tell her bro that's why i said
that when they were fighting and it's
gonna happen
you said you wanted to start over oh
don't do this
no eve was wrong about you oh man
damn you gotta tell her bro you gotta
tell her ever since mark got his ass
whooped in the last episode i get so
concerned now when he's in a fight
yeah i'm like oh no he could really get
hurt
oh god robot no ho ho
what the
when she was injured i immediately
dispatched a drone to the arctic
this is a cerulean cosmos it contains a
unique molecule that i believe will add
sixty percent to her chances of survival
says multiple bodies
why does he care so much about her
there's some sort of past there also i
was very wrong earlier about
about the douchebag being robot yeah
i'll take it back
thanks thanks for coming oh she knows
the suit guy
is that mark hamill is that mark hamill
i think someone said mark hamill's in
the show
he's trying to put it off i hear it now
it is
oh [ __ ] now i can't unhear it oh [ __ ]
no guys see these flakes
they look like gold but they're much
harder i've only seen them
one other place or woman's armor
there's too much evidence yep friction
burns from something moving real fast
dude debbie don't don't tell him maybe
they attacked him first
maybe blood begins to oxidize when
exposed to air
i can measure it see how long since it
was spilled
this is the oldest blood on the suit oh
nolan struck first
[Music]
don't tell anyone not cecil no one or
i'll send no one to kill you
oh no he knows why he's gonna kill you
jeffy he's gonna
murder you does he have super hearing
i don't know they haven't established
that if he does i'll go down to the
store and grab some beer
i'll stay here make sure they don't
murder each other you're gonna get
abducted man
yeah buddy you're invincible not
now man and you never told me
[Music]
that would be my reaction
so what made you think she was gonna be
a villain
i don't know it just she seemed like it
just
felt that way i'll get it to later
yeah it looks like wrong i'm kyle good
for you
i'm sorry i'm amber loki mega party at
our house tonight
yo you guys hungry should i grab some
pizza
no love it no mushrooms everything okay
with the love birds
[Music]
yikes face time like that
rick you there mark he called it
something happened to rick we were on
the phone and it cut off we need to look
for him i need to go after amber
call me if you really can't find rick
but i gotta go after amber first
oh that's not good that's so fat fast
[Music]
alienating the people in your life
no no come on he's such a sweet old man
don't kill mark campbell okay good
now that's a good mislead
that's a good misdirection a person's
life is in danger
help them no now his friend might die
i feel like i know what's going to
happen
are you there no but kurt connors is
crap
oh no
is she already making out with the guy
no oh good oh
oh i'm so happy no get your [ __ ] hand
off of her
you're a little nerdy for a frackie no
no no don't do this amber don't do this
my girlfriend says the same thing not
now william
you gotta tell her man please just tell
her i i can't hear you i'll see you back
at rick's storm
god damn it mark
you're bad what do you mean ah there's
no conflict now go
you're brave you're friends what matters
most you've known for years yeah him
oh that's so heartbreaking
why the same thing i'm about to do with
you
god that reminded me of loki with the
eye thing from avengers oh yeah
yeah yeah good place to start
i swear man if he if william dies i'm
gonna get
pretty upset i'm gonna hate you yeah i'm
gonna hate you mark if your friend does
stab dude what did you do with william
oh no oh crap how are you gonna stop
all of them bro oh no oh no
god those punches really hit oh nothing
you really do i feel it all yeah he
needs another super saiyan moment
from last episode
stop don't do this it's no use appealing
to his emotions
[Music]
i was gonna hate you when you get out of
this
it's us it's me we met last year
at the lake
the boathouse god
damn damn we had sex by the water it was
the
best thing that ever happened
oh my god oh
[Applause]
yeah damn get him
heal that
[Laughter]
great back fist that was nice
yeah did you get
what you want to say i'm sorry just lost
it
don't beat yourself up has he won a
single fight yet
in the show he won that fight through
there i mean [ __ ] what's his name
help with that
like by himself
amber totally slept with that guy it
makes me so sad
no amber didn't sleep with that guy i
feel like she's going too though
she's going to catch them oh good what's
wrong with you you misjudged people
it's so harsh you're sexist
oh god thank god i guess she knows she
i think she did something with him she'd
do anything with him why do you why do
you
put this on her because
he is so comforting i don't know man
[Laughter]
why oh no why what
why did you do it i didn't do anything
don't
lie to me i know i know you
killed them noah we'll talk about this
tomorrow yeah
don't do that your house is bugged
[Music]
okay good okay what a great shot
he's just in his own dark hole oh man
wait that's right they do [ __ ] okay keep
wanting to turn it off
i don't know man my stepdad could lose
his job at the white house
who is this guy that's the one dude's
son
yeah i know but like we keep coming back
to this
we dig up the immortal drink from his
skull and wham oh nice we get his power
that's right they mentioned gravedigging
dude i saw it on reddit don't believe
everything you read on the internet kids
oh no
[Music]
oh wow wow
i'm hoping i misjudged amber
i think you did i feel like i did i mean
what if it happened behind
go fine he said he had a girlfriend
coming up
going up there and come on i'd be so
cliche if she slept with him
it would be if mark saw them kissing
might have been cliche but
if i had to choose between like them
seeing each other and then
sleeping together and then him going to
save his friend
kids in college never behave that way
okay
trust me i was home schooled all right
all righty hell of an episode there huh
yeah aaron
take it away what was it of why you
love this one so much why did this one
connect with you more than
why did this one connect with you
actually i hated this one uh it's my
least favorite i can
tell no man i think a lot
happened in terms of of character growth
and the
i mean not even character growth but
seeing
mark deal with the trials and
tribulations of balancing the friends
stuff and the lady stuff
it very much reminded me of spider-man
uh
as i probably said before a million
times the difference between
mark and peter is the fact that his
figure of
the most important staple in his life
that
formulates him as a hero is his dad and
some extent his mom as well
so he kind of has a habit of making the
the more selfish choice
i'm [ __ ] man i'm gonna go see him i'm
gonna go find out about my girlfriend
as opposed to helping out your your guy
and you know bit him in the ass a little
bit
uh i mean he didn't bite him in the ass
because he he ended up going to save his
friend
um yeah what do you think man
i say words i just want you to get on
like a webcam one day
she's like hey here's my thoughts on
invincible oh bring these out as i'm
talking with you guys
yeah i thought it was great i don't know
where i rank it doesn't really matter it
progresses the story forward in ways
that i appreciate i don't know what's
gonna happen with omniman and debbie
that's a scary scenario to be in he has
a purpose for doing it and i just and
it's like we're building up so much
to what is the reason what is the cause
for why he did it
it's like you can see a version where he
kills debbie but there's also this party
he's like but maybe he wouldn't because
he really does love her and it feels
like he really does love and care for
her
yeah i think what this show has done a
good job at is he doesn't look like he's
complete sociopath it feels like there
are things he genuinely has a
heart for that he really cares about
like even with art
he was trying to find out the truth
about him but he didn't even he didn't
off him
right you know when he could have easily
like picking it away killing the
guardians
you know killing art i feel like he at
that point knew his wife knows something
and i feel like killing art would kind
of
reinforce her suspicion so i don't think
it was for art's sake i think it was for
his marriage and his wife's sake
then that happened or maybe like the way
when he killed the guardians that was
more methodical
in terms of how he planned for when to
do it and the cameras and all that
was art not really planned for that
either way
i feel like with nolan we're building to
a point that's going to be
so intense and so scary it's so crazy i
just want to get there i just want to
know the answers
and what they've been doing with mark is
really really great too i i prefer the
challenging characters i prefer a
character that'll piss me off i prefer a
character that'll
make me be like man i'm frustrated with
you but it's also very human what you
would do
you know like i make sense the position
he's in
like can you blame him same thing you
know it's
like it's easy for me to be in an
audience member seat and be
frustrated and judge this guy there are
parts of it where i think it's totally
valid to get annoyed this guy seems like
he's actually in physical danger
and this guy who you're staying in his
dorm he's letting you stay here he seems
like he's in physical danger right now
yeah and then even when he sees the
footage of william and the robot guy he
has a moment of hesitation of do i talk
with amber or save my friend i'm like
come on man you gotta say save your
friend whatever are you even
contemplating right now all right get
out of there right now you know there
are aspects of it that do that do feel
realistic in that in that regard and i i
like the fact that yourself
and now most humans are selfish and i
feel like if you're in this position you
have all these powers and you want to
have like it's a girlfriend and stuff
that's what i mean it's i i'm frustrated
as an audience
but i'm almost like i get it you right
you hate it because you can you can
empathize with it you can see yourself
in those shoes
and something else i really was
something else
something else i really what what i had
a list
what happened
[Laughter]
something else that i really enjoyed was
the fact that
something else oh composure something
else i really enjoyed
was the fact that his friend william
immediately recognized him as invincible
in the costume
he's underneath them and normally in
other superhero properties like superman
or spider-man like when when the people
in your life that you're saving
recognize your voice or recognize
your face and he knew immediately he's
like mark i'm like thank you
because that is something that would
happen yeah i mean he's looking up above
them and i like that shot of like super
power beans
having a battle among over this over
this human
and everybody but with his perspective
it's he's looking at the shape of his
face and you're like that's definitely
more
yeah and i love that hair i love the way
he was behaving you know
like to fly oh take me flying now i want
to fly
how could you not have told me i loved
like the selfish humor that comes out of
the characters here
yeah especially with him too the cool
thing about this show is
in spite of the fact that it's animated
you still feel the tension of
real people within this like when mark
and
and amber are having those disputes you
feel it when even despite the fact that
this is all like
drawn in on computers when when cecil
and
nolan are having that confrontation it
feels so tense
and i'm like oh my god like it's like
the game of like who knows what you know
like they both know
that the other knows something they both
know something's off and like there's
this like unspoken threat level there
or threatening nature there yeah they're
figuring each other out and every line
that cecil is saying
saying about dark blood but like his
words sound like they're about dark
blood but we know he's really talking
about omni man you know
yeah exactly i do enjoy that kind of
dialogue and that play yeah i feel like
cecil
you know in the way he had an
interaction with uh mark at the end too
like that's right you know i feel like
this guy really does care about his job
who cares about people you know he come
across a little harsh a little bit like
a dick sometimes but
at the end of the day he has a heart
this guy really cares yeah yeah yeah
this i think this episode displayed a
lot of heart that would be like one of
the key words i would say for this one
the robot stuff with um monster girl
there we go
that stuff was really was really
compelling yeah i don't know what's
going on did they explain it did i miss
it
oh and why you care so much about her no
but it looks like robot has multiple
bodies that's new information to us
and that means like it's like like it
seems like robot is the ai
that it lives and breathes right where
you know how like tony stark and iron
man 3 is able to produce like
multiple iron man suits that are robots
and move but they don't have like
sentient thought processes prior to this
point i thought it was like a roma
robot man kind of situation not the fact
that he's human even though they've
alluded to that i think
more so like this is his solitary body
yeah it does seem more of like an ai
kind of ultron sort of scenario well i
mean everyone just says he's a robot and
they talk so specifically about
how he's just a robot how do you like
them like even samson's questioning
right why do you care so much for just a
robot yeah how can you feel that to this
degree i thought robot shouldn't be able
to feel like this yeah i think
that whole scenario and what's going on
with him is just as interesting to me as
the the omni man stuff yeah i love
watching um i just love extreme height
and emotions
i love watching people who are pushed to
intense emotions out of care something
about that that is so
gripping watching robot feel that way
because
you know his robot he's always kind of
had an artificial way of presenting
himself and you'll find out zachary
kinto voicing him who also plays spock
and spock's
learning about how to not feel his
emotions you know i was like okay it was
kind of meta-casting in a certain sense
but then to get these sides where he
clearly acknowledges what he cares about
even though he's programmed to he's
clearly
more selective about monster girl which
i i really appreciate but at the same
time he's doing like you don't know what
he's doing with uh what are those clones
names
what are those those guys the mueller
twins yeah
yeah the originals i love the nuances
that you get with each one of these
characters
because even they it's been established
for a while they're really really hyper
smart but they're also
intense buff cree they they're not
stupid
no bullhead just go and charging type of
characters only they're also
incredibly intelligent beings as well
their physical statures contrast
to their their mental and even like the
villain in this episode at the campus
which feels a little random
go to go visit a campus supervillain
living in again this is
this is the only one that felt like
villain of the week it felt a little
episodic
yeah yeah i enjoyed the character stuff
but the villain stuff
felt very much adult version of like a
saturday
cartoon with like oh the villain on the
campus taking over the people and oh
we stopped them by the end you know yeah
the last time i felt that way was like
earthquake man but earthquake man
came in kind of at the last minute he
wasn't a central focus of the episode
from beginning to end like this episode
starts off with him
yeah with uh whoever this person on
campus is i forget his name
uh little dick man i don't know oh my
gosh
it's like a t-d-a something uh doesn't
matter
yeah he's he's gone he's done but
there's something to his
there's something to his evil madman
reasoning that i
i appreciated there's something there
where i was like guys got a point
we advance everything through machinery
and technology and if we
review the human body as the human
machine maybe there's a way to fix it
like
there were parts of my mind they were
going yeah solid point for a mad villain
all right i can get on board with his
causes not that i agree with what he's
doing but it's cool when you can get
the philosophical perspective of your
villain of the episode and be like
actually
i totally get where he's coming from
there's some there's some logic to what
he's saying
and there's there are consensual ways to
do that but
yeah totally he was totally failing at
it yeah but it does seem like a villain
where you're like is this
as focused as he was will it tie into
the rest of the season i think we have a
lot of
moving pieces and we have two episodes
left with
you know the the space stuff of like the
the alien on the ship
and then the tomb of all that and then i
don't know if we're gonna go back to
no the the aliens that were got old
they're they're done right they're
they're mars oh yeah we have aliens from
mars but i was talking also talking
about the
the alien race that no one went through
the portal like oh yeah yeah
they're wiped out yeah yeah he he
extinct them and then you got a
nolan the guardians that to resolve that
got dark blood
how many episodes are there in total or
left
uh in total are supposed to be in the
season do you know eight episodes that's
it
yeah so i got two left after this we
have two left dance lots of wrap-up
[Laughter]
or yeah season two is already renewed
okay yeah i don't know what the
situation is
i hope it's a two uh two season a year
kind of thing that'd be cool
yeah okay well there's a lot to wrap up
adam
eve it just seemed like she had villains
set up
uh reject like parents who really reject
her she wants to do good but she's being
judged
heavily for just who she is and who but
she was born as rejected by her parents
there's something about it where
i feel like it's trying to mislead me
but then this show sometimes
often goes against the grain and goes
against the cliche maybe my mind is just
so used to what the cliche would do
and that's why i thought adam eve would
go down that path the same way why i
think you think amber was sleeping with
that guy
uh yes i think that's why i was thinking
adam eve would go down that path but
i don't know i mean i could be wrong i
would i'm at the point where i wouldn't
be surprised
rex cheated on her her family rejects
who she is what she is she's completely
isolated now
she doesn't get the respect she deserves
she seems like she's caught feelings for
mark who's soon
super into someone else i mean it
doesn't mean yeah like when you lay all
those things out it does make sense yeah
but as we've seen with the show thus far
without fail it does this thing where
like it sets up things and cliches that
we expect and then just tilt it slightly
yeah that's that's what i mean is i can
see myself being way wrong too but then
you got amber here i feel like she would
have put put it together that mark is
probably invincible
yeah i don't know why you wouldn't tell
her smart character she
is i think she would have put it
together in that moment yeah like how he
could just
like come on she she's they've shown how
smart she is
right like mark is there one second she
turns around he's
vanished another second a guy with a
similar physique to mark shows up
saves the day the second he's gone mark
shows back like you can put it together
i know in the midst of the moment of
being exposed to all this
i guess it would be different if you
didn't live in a world where superheroes
are part of the norm
you know what i mean like if there was
one superhero
yeah the way how it was sometimes
presented in the spider-man world like
in the movies so i can get why some
people wouldn't suspect it's
peter parker but in this world full of
superheroes it's like anyone could be
disguised as a superhero right yeah
and it's pretty logical to conclude that
mark would be a superhero and
most of his face is exposed and his hair
and he keeps getting like
he gets his ass whooped like i got hit
by a bust you wouldn't let me see me in
the h i feel like there's just so many
things where amber as smart of a
character as she is
as observant of a character as she is
she would have put this together by now
i'm really hoping they have a moment
where
she's like oh okay that all makes sense
like i'm really curious to see what her
reaction will eventually be
when we do get that reveal it does serve
great purpose for
mark and his struggle of having a
balanced personal life
with being a superhero and it's funny
because we joked before about
william and how we couldn't remember his
name how he didn't really seem like how
much of a presence or personality and
then here you get so much focus on him
you don't like
flesh his character out from beginning
to end you know he's still like
funny best friend uh kind of ned leads
so you also get the other shades of him
where you see him like
break down in tears and how much he
really cares about the guy who they're
visiting on campus
i forgot his name uh rick rick
really cares about rick and there was
such a tragedy to what happened with
rick
in the end of it all but even there i
was like oh this is great that you get
it opportu
i was gonna be pissed if they kill them
off in this episode because i'm like
damn marking your
freaking decision making but also this
is the first episode where i really
cared or actually even really
liked william i'd be bummed to kill them
off here
but i love how you even got more shades
to him he has a personality but
underneath the personalities is
really caring dude you know and that's
what i mean by a lot of heart like when
he saw rick he starts crying
heartbroken over it he really cares
about mark all these qualities
there's a lot of love on display in this
episode and a lot of tragedy as well
amber and mark
not making it happen um but yeah
i guess i had a harder time kind of
getting into that because i was
to be honest with you guys like i
couldn't help separate myself from the
fact that
i feel like amber would have put this
together by now maybe maybe not the
exact
moment but after like a few couple hours
i think from settling down and being
angry at mark you might be like
wait a minute right i feel like one
party has to be like wait a minute right
it's weird how it does this is this
thing where it subverts traditional
superhero property expectations but also
playing into them that's one of the
biggest ones that it's doing so far but
it's part of
the superhero movie show whatever game
you know where the where the love
interest is oblivious and then finally
finds out and you know you know they're
gonna do it but i look forward to seeing
when that finally does come to a head
you know if she's gonna accept that
if she's gonna go the route of like gwen
stacy or
are going to work out you know because
we still have to deal with the the adam
eve
love triangle scenario like what adam
and mark would be like but you know
that's later that's later down the line
i'm very much invested in the amber
amber and mark of it all i'm really
charmed by amber yeah
i'm trying by adam too i guess i'm i'm
at a point where i'm like
dude i don't feel like you need to be
with amber though
um you know what i mean like i like them
together and i think they're cute
together
but it's it doesn't feel like this is
the love of his life
no whereas to compare it with countless
other comic book counterparts you know
clark cannon lois lane
and peter parker mary jane you're like
that's the love of their life
i feel very i don't know if this is a
love of your life
kind of stuff but it feels very much
like first love kind of stuff like i
don't think
that's fair i don't feel like they've
never i don't feel like they have
established that mark has been in
anything sort of romantic
prior to this this is gwen stacy she's
definitely the gwen stacy
[Laughter]
if her death or if she dies is gonna be
a lot more violent than gwen stacy's was
yeah it's true i hope battle beast
doesn't murder her
and they have uh increased physicality
stakes by the fact how mark did get his
ass whooped
yeah because now when he gets hurt
before it's like it'll be fine you're
invincible
now you're like oh dude this could be
bad yeah that's the other thing i like i
feel like
the contrast with the title card of
invincible with the blood and then
seeing the market every episode like get
his
ass kicked yeah it doesn't seem to be
really bad he doesn't seem to be any
stronger
it's getting worse it makes us relate to
him more or like makes us care about him
more because he's not
invincible he's like the the most
fragile character that of the show you
know aside from the humans but
you know he's the most fragile superhero
of the show but it's a good show it's a
great show damn good [ __ ] damn good
television
um yeah i can't wait to see this all
concludes man this damn this is great
stuff
all right guys well invincible episode
six what did you all think leave your
thoughts down below what do you
completely disagree with the song what
do you 100
agree with us on what are you in the
middle of the road subscribe to real
rejects
clicks to the notification bell hit the
like button follow aaron on instagram
thank you for thought for any of the
highlights last but not least
rosa parra independent ass
latina right she's been part of patreon
page
forever loyal follower and then one and
she's also
in the medical field works in a hospital
and then she decided to pursue her
passion of
getting into film criticism and really
uh
going into the latin market inside she's
really a certified critic she's already
really been growing so much
so fast in the past year and a half it's
crazy while raising a family
and just today of filming this
lin-manuel miranda followed her on
twitter
what that's awesome you were you were
killing it
she's killing the the life game she took
a shot
and said i am not
[Laughter]
[Music]
but rosa um i wish i was
uh in the room when it happened
[Laughter]
oh my god really soaring in the heights
right now i'm really
all
proud
[Music]